ah ah ah então esta festa é super
estrela a série difícil é muito
decidiram que a 2 224 bichos na minha
porta e depois ao mesmo tempo eu sou fã
há lógica substituo nilton que algumas
glórias festa porque ele não merece nem
os pais deviam saber o que ela vai fazer
passar a sua tarefa é seu programa de
ajustamento obrigado por me colocar na
posição é do méxico a seguirem
considerou que o dia todo e saiu à meia
noite e pouco se chegar até a final e só
de judd apatow e tempo meu feito por um
dos filhos da mãe filho da mãe a mãe
ficará em raposas que não tem um biótipo
um corpo meu deus como chegou perto mas
agora eu não tô não pode não pode
[Música]
o edu também é quente agora sou muito
menina nasceu o rei sol os peluches o
mataram este mesmo o último muito medo
quando conhecimento eu canto conseguir
passar a noite sempre põe pra eu vou
cantar dentro
o medo hoje aparecem mas quem se dar por
que é que tu quem texto tem medo [ __ ]
da imagem nenhuma essa imagem nenhuma
mas também já fui campeão aqui porque
alguma coisa não é discutível estão
abertas dito macro futuro e chorou muito
inchado e fica aí bater na porta e cair
a senhora já foi embora e não perto de
mim
o gato não conseguimos porque passa
agora eu já sei usar silva pereira
anunciou o título se não não denunciou o
ataque ocorre um pato
segundo pattoli ii foi boa agora
[Música]
os atacou e pizzi amigo
enfim fechada que o porto domingo os
ataques em peshawar que o poeta nenhum
não da coxa não conseguiu fechar não não
algumas estado
[Música]
esse mundaréu josé raposa já no segundo
a equipe da casa e eu não cantei a
partida assim meu como é qualquer coisa
que o espera
[Música]
o cadê meus não não falava lá não não
não não
[Música]
eu sentei no botão no chamado livro pra
você apanhar ou não da fresh do lixo
filha de um corno da porta não fãs
agora vou ver a quebra e de pigmeu
aparece pintado
eu não vou me muito
digo que eu passei por favor eu tive que
horas horas os garis por favor meu tudo
isso pra não do jogo eu passei muito
tempo meu ok estamos mais outro cheque
de 120 dólares tudo bem não quer saber
do dinheiro pra nada
sua série no tive que muito muito muito
tempo eu não sei acho que vão pra umas
quatro ou cinco horas jogar esta
porcaria e finalmente consegui chegar ao
fim de sua fala sério